let's do some more problems involving
Newton's laws okay so this problem that
I'm picking from this is I think it's
from Oregon University
it's ZEB you that you or again that edu
only come credit for their problems but
let's see let me draw it's gonna be the
ground okay and then the problem says
that I have a train on the rest of this
is a train try my best to draw a train I
don't know something like that I mean
there's smoke coming out and it says the
Train of mass six point eight four so
let's say the mass of the train the mass
of the train is six point eight four
times 10 to the sixth kilograms that's
the mass of this train is moving at a
speed of 80 kilometers per hour so it's
velocity we could say its initial
velocity because I think it's gonna ask
me what happens to its velocity so its
initial velocity is equal to 80
kilometers per hour and see the brakes
so it's going this way at 80 km/h 80
millimetres per hour the brakes which
produce a net backward force of so the
baek's are gonna are gonna pull
backwards right they're gonna a net
backward force of one point so force is
equal to one point nine three times 10
to the sixth Newtons that's one point
nine three times ten to the six Newtons
I know it looks a little bit messy
that's and that the brakes are going to
be applied for 25 seconds so the so the
force of the I'll say force sub B or the
force of the brakes is 1.93
times 10 to the 6 Newtons and then they
will be applied for 25 seconds so the
first question they ask is what is the
new speed of the train so what is the
speed of the train after the brakes are
applied for 25 seconds well all we have
to figure out is is how fast is the
train decelerating or what rate of
deceleration does this bat backward
force create so we go just go back to
our basics
let me switch colors because this Reds
getting little monotonous force is equal
to mass times acceleration probably the
easiest formula ever to memorize and
what's the backward force the backward
force is 1.93 times 10 to the 6 so 1
point 9 3 times 10 to the 6
and that equals mass times acceleration
what's the mass mass is right here six
point six point zero that's a decimal
there's six point eight 4 times 10 to
the 6 times acceleration right and
acceleration is what we're trying to
figure out and remember if the force is
pulling back then of course the
acceleration is also going to be
backwards or it's going to essentially
slow down the Train so I know this is
very messy but let's just divide well we
could divide both sides by 10 to the 6
just to get that out of the way and then
simplifies things a little bit and then
we're left with the acceleration I'm
just flipping both sides this equation
acceleration is equal to one point nine
three divided by six point eight four
and this is going to be give going to be
given in meters per second squared
right and I just want to make sure I got
my all of my units right right because
this number here the mass was in
kilograms
right and then the force was given in
Newtons so the acceleration will be in
meters per second squared and let's get
the handy calculator here because this
looks I don't want to waste your time
reviewing how to divide decimals
although that might not be a bad review
most people forget one point nine three
divided by six point whoops I think I
messed up let me see one point nine
three divided by six point eight four is
0.28 two so acceleration so it's
acceleration equals MA is equal to 0.28
let's just say - eight - meters per
second squared and so how fast is the
train going to be going after 25 seconds
so what's the change in velocity well
the change change in velocity is equal
to acceleration times time
and if we take its velocity as a
positive number then its acceleration
will be a negative number right because
it's going to be going in the it's going
to be going in the opposite direction
good night the other way around so the
change in velocity is going to be equal
to this minus 0.282 meters per second
squared I won't write the unit's here
because I'm running out of space
- 0.28 - meters per second squared times
25 seconds and let's get the calculator
back here where you go there it is okay
so now we want to multiply that number
we just figured out times 25 times 25
equals 7.05 7.05 so the change in
velocity change in velocity is equal to
minus 7.0 five meters per second okay so
let's see what's going on the original
initial speed of the train is 80
kilometers per hour but we have the
change in velocity given in meters per
second
so what we could either can change this
change in velocity into kilometers per
hour or we could go the other way around
and do the or change the kilometers per
hour into meters per second I don't know
let's change the meters per second into
kilometers per hour so there are how
many meters so it'll be minus 7.05 and
how many meters are there in a kilometer
well there are thousand meters in a
kilometer so it's going to be going that
number divided by a thousand kilometers
and you if this is a little confusing
I'm skipping a couple of steps you might
want to review the video on unit
conversion and then this is meters per
second but we want to get kilometers per
hour so it'll go how many seconds are
there in an hour there's 3,600 right so
it'll go 3,600 times as far in an hour
as it does in a second some times 3,600
and so we can get rid of two zeros here
and two zeros here so it's essentially
going to be 7.05
times 36 I just got rid of zeros I'll
write the zeros they're just so confused
divided by a thousand one one two three
equals twenty five point three nine km/h
so I'll just I'll just round twenty five
kilometres per hour
so the change in velocity is minus
twenty five kilometers per hour so
that's that's how much what's the change
in velocity if it was starting off at 80
kilometers and then the change in
velocity is minus twenty-five
what's its new velocity well it's going
to be 80 minus twenty five the initial
velocity minus the change in velocity or
plus the change in velocity depending on
how you view that negative number so
eighty minus twenty five so we could say
the final velocity the final velocity is
going to be eighty minus 25 is 55
kilometers per hour now the second part
of this question is how far has a train
traveled in this time so essentially how
long how far does a train how far does
the train go as it breaks from 80
kilometers per hour to 55 kilometers per
hour well all we have to figure out is
the average velocity and then multiply
that times the time right so what's the
average velocity here let me let me well
actually let me just clear this because
I think it's getting to you don't use a
drawing of a train see if I remember my
so the initial velocity was 80
kilometers per hour final velocity is 55
kilometers per hour so the average
velocity is going to be 80 plus 55 over
2 which is what 67 and a half something
like that right 67 and a half 67 and a
half kilometers per hour and then if we
want to figure out the total distance it
travels distance is equal to voyage
velocity times time the average velocity
well we have the time in seconds right
so we have 25 seconds here
but this is given in kilometers per hour
so we want to convert this into maybe
m/s so we will do is take the sixty
seven point five it's going to go times
a thousand that's how many meters it's
going to go and then in a second it's
gonna go one thirty six hundredths of
that let's see what that gives us sixty
seven point five times one thousand
divided by 3600 eighteen point seven
five eighteen point seven five that's
the meters per second that's the average
velocity in meters per second and we go
for 25 seconds so what does that give us
times 25 equals four hundred and sixty
eight meters four hundred sixty eight
point seven five meters that's how far
it traveled just to break from 80
kilometers per hour to 55 kilometers per
hour and it took 25 seconds hopefully I
haven't confused you too much see you
soon